[Music]
your hands are really dexterous things
we use them every day for all sorts of
tasks
to make the best use we possibly can of
that is to build a puppet around the
hand so knuckles become knees or elbows
at the end of the day it's all the
illusion of movement
my name's barnaby dickson i'm a
puppeteer
all right
i'm 26 years old and i started making
puppets two years ago
this is dab chick
this is the first puppet i ever made
this is manu
and it takes two hands to operate this
puppet
[Music]
and this is the dinosaur i think this is
the most expressive puppet that i have
[Music]
i make them in my room really
each of these puppets represents maybe
two months work and it's it's a process
that's driven completely by trial and
error
the materials to make these puppets are
usually you can just get them online raw
bits of metal or plumber's epoxy just
things like that really
hey barnaby dixon here
i made the puppets originally with the
purpose to create uh video content on
youtube so check this out
most weeks i'll take dab chick out for
an outing where i'll film it ah the
great british seaside soft wet sand oh
joy of joys
i always do try and make them funny the
proud fury of the waves thundering to
earth
i do get self-conscious about having the
puppets out and about
some people just think i'm an adult
playing with a toy
people kind of don't know what to think
of it
[Music]
hello
[Music]
so recently i was on a german talent
show that was about puppets it was
called de poop and stars
and i ended up winning this
it was very validating and so i think
yeah a lot of people would think it's
quite a weird thing for a
26 year old to be in his bedroom making
puppets but it's working out for me so
huh
[Music]
you